je veux juste quelque chose pour avoir plus de
temps que d'heures dans la journée
où le reste n'a jamais atteint le quota mes
unités sont en hausse par rapport à la semaine dernière donc son quota de
deux heures ça a toujours été une heure beaucoup
à prix a augmenté jusqu'à notre marche j'ai une
heure  et demi et tu ferais mieux de courir
les pauvres sont censés mourir
c'est comme ça que le système fonctionne comment c'est
censé être tu ne sais vraiment pas
tu sais il sera en temps réel 28 105
la vérité est qu'il y a plus qu'assez de
temps pour tout le monde  ils sont avec un
million d'années presque au jour le jour pour que
quelques-uns soient immortels beaucoup doivent mourir personne ne
devrait être immortel même une personne
doit mourir
vous n'êtes pas d'ici êtes-
vous pourquoi douteriez-vous que vous '  re un peu
différent venez avec moi les
caméras ont capté un comportement suspect
son nom est will Salas vous ne devriez pas être
là qu'est-ce qu'on va faire voler
voler si c'est déjà volé je ne les
fais pas payer
allez aidez vous je suis un  arbre
assez bon hein
on ne peut pas avoir mille ans
entre de mauvaises mains  Je vais paralyser le système
Je vais l'arrêter Le
problème est que tout le monde veut vivre
éternellement Nous ne sommes pas censés vivre éternellement
Ne pas venir à la cuisine Espérons que
son crime ne prenait pas de temps, il vous le
donnait